- All right, we've got
one last feel-good story
to close out this hour.
This is What I'm Liking.
(dramatic drum beats)
(audience cheering)
An Idaho mama has launched an
HGTV style series on TikTok,
but this one seems just
a little more achievable
to lots of people out there,
given that it's gotten more
than 3.6 million views.
Take a look.
- Entry space is the first impression.
Choose design elements
that say welcome to my beautiful home.
Immediately when you walk in,
the layout says casual elegance.
Nothings says, welcome in,
like some items of interest
displayed on your area rug.
Like a dog collar,
some fruit snacks, some tape,
and the dog hair kind
of ties it all together.
We have an open area
underneath our stairs.
I like to call this my
farmhouse chic area.
Choose our great design element
and don't be afraid to mix them up.
We have an UGG up here,
boots, tennis shoes,
and just one flip flop,
and balance it all out with
a hoodie throw on the ground,
and a hair tie up on the bench.
- All right, so we have the woman
behind the decor by Jody
TikToks, on the line right now,
watching on KXLY TV at 4:00 PM.
What's up Jody?
(audience cheering)
- Hi Kelly.
- Girl, you...
I like almost had all
my makeup redone again.
That video is so funny.
What inspired these videos and
what inspired you to do it?
- Well, we love our house,
but it's always messy,
and it seems like no
matter how hard I try,
I can't get it organized.
And I thought,
well maybe there's
something funny about that.
Because, like when I look at
a table and I'll see a hammer,
or an empty bag of chips, dental floss.
(Kelly laughs)
I'm like why?
I mean, technically we are empty nesters,
but there always seems to
be people coming and going
from our house.
Like our grown kids will
stop by, or their friends.
We babysit our nieces sometimes.
And I'm technically
kinda still on mom duty,
which I'm so grateful for.
But then I'll look around and I'll say.
- But pick up your crap.
- Somebody better pickup all the shoes.
(Kelly laughing)
- I'm really grateful for
it, but pick up your stuff.
- Then I realize they're all my shoes.
- Oh my God, I love that you're like,
it's really interesting to mix it up,
mix the shoes up.
(laughs)
So when you say that
you have a lot of people
who can relate,
I am one of them, by the way,
like this must have resonated
with so many people out there.
- Yeah, that's been really fun.
Like a lot of the comments are,
"How did you get into my house?"
Or, "Do you have a hidden
camera in my kitchen?"
And I think a lot of people
are on the decor by Jody trend,
and they don't even know it.
And Kelly, I have to tell you,
(Kelly laughs)
I have to tell you, Kelly,
my favorite song of yours
has always been "Beautiful Disaster".
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- And so now I guess that's my theme song.
- You are so funny, Jody.
I love you so much for this.
It's so funny, everybody
out there relates to this.
And we're all trying to keep
it clean, but somehow, yep,
just crap ends up everywhere.
And that's everyone's house with kids.
Thank you so much Jody.
I'm liking your posts right now, right?
- [Jody] Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- And that's not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot, pen makers of Frixion,
the go to erasable pen of
The Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like you ma'am.
So they're gonna give you
$1,000 to help you out.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you so much.
- You can at least pay someone
to come in and clean it up
so you don't have to do that.